hey you guys flickers of fear time
once again so today i actually wanted to
talk about
the movie the other lamb now this movie
i guess it premiered at the toronto
international film festival back in
autumn of 2019
and then was kind of picked up for
distribution so it actually the
interesting thing about this was that
it was released i believe in the us
in april of 2020 like right around the
time of all the you know coveted
shutdowns and everything
so it was very strange that because it
was briefly released in the theater and
it was actually for a time
the third highest grossing movie that
had been released even though it only
made like
less than five thousand dollars because
so few people went to see it
so i just thought that was an
interesting little piece of trivia so
yeah so this movie i actually watched on
hulu
i'm sure you can probably watch it some
other places as well and i was kind of
interested
in seeing it because i don't know i just
kind of heard a lot of things about it
and uh it seemed very like folk horror
and you know kind of about a cult and
stuff and i'm always kind of really into
that kind of stuff
so i was finally i was glad i finally
got to watch it i will say
okay i'm going to say like right from
the outset
if you liked midsummer if you liked
the witch if you like this kind of like
real slow burn
like this really visually rich
sort of um you know but but stuff where
it's mostly visual there's not a lot of
dialogue there's not it's not real
action-packed it's not real gory
or anything like that it has like some
unsettling images and things like that
at various points
but it's not i don't even know if i i
guess it's sort of like a horror movie
but it's more like i said it's more like
folk horror or it's more like a weird
unsettling nightmarish sort of drama
that has like horror elements to it
so just kind of know that going into
it's very kind of arty
and um you know because i you know i
usually like that kind of thing uh but i
know a lot of people don't and it's you
know i'm not
i'm not judging or anything like that
i'm just saying that that's the kind of
movie it is
uh so if that does not sound like
something that you want to watch uh then
maybe you should skip this one also has
uh some handmaid's tale
elements to it too so you might be into
that so this was actually directed by
and i'm sure i'm going to pronounce her
name wrong
so please forgive me but it's uh i think
it's mal gorzada
zamovska and she's a polish film
director this is she's made films before
this her first uh
english language film now when i was
first watching it the
the young woman that plays uh the main
character sella
uh she's her name is raffy cassidy and i
was like man she is so
so familiar and uh the reason that i
saw her the reason that i knew who she
was was because i had seen her
in vox lux she was also in killing of a
sacred deer uh the yorkis lanthamos
movie which i actually haven't seen yet
but it's on my list
i'm gonna be reviewing it in a month or
something like that i can't remember
where it is on the schedule but it is uh
coming up because i've been wanting to
see that for a long time too
and uh it also stars again i'm probably
going to pronounce this wrong too but i
guess like michael heisman oisman i
don't know he's from game of thrones
uh and he's dutch so i'm sure i'm
probably pronouncing his name wrong so
uh as i said this is a very folk horror
it's a cult horror essentially
so the setup of the movie is that sella
she's a teenage girl you're presuming
she's
14 something like that and she has been
in this cult presumably since she was
born because she does
talk up to one of the other uh women
that's in the cult later on and they
talk about her mother
who presumably died in childbirth you
know you kind of find out some different
[ __ ] later on
but so she's been in this cult her whole
life
now the interesting thing about this
cult so it's all
women but uh
you know the the main guy who is just
called the shepherd so he's this
jesus looking dude he thinks he's jesus
obviously
and he has essentially a harem and there
are
i don't know i guess probably like maybe
20 24 like maybe a couple dozen
women and girls in his flock as he calls
it
and they are divided into wives
and daughters or sisters they call them
that as well
and so they have like these color-coded
outfits so like the daughters and the
sisters who presumably are
you know pre-menstrual um you know so
they're pre-pubescent
they wear kind of like blue dresses
you know kind of just those long prairie
sort of 19th century kind of
dresses and um you know little green
coats over it
whereas the wives wear red
they don't really tell you where this is
set it's
basically this cult they live out in the
middle of nowhere it's just these it's
this kind of collection of cabins
out in the wilderness at first when i
was watching it i thought it was maybe
the pacific northwest or something like
that and i
saw later that they actually shot it in
ireland um
i guess i didn't realize it was ireland
because i don't know i just associate
ireland with like being a lot more
the you know the green and stuff being a
lot more vibrant but i guess like the
cinematography they kind of like leeched
some of the color out
i think they did that because one of the
most striking things about this movie
at least from a visual standpoint is how
the very saturated colors of the
women's uh clothing is really like
contrasted against this sort of
you know this sort of desaturated um but
still beautiful
background of this you know forest and
mountains where they live
so they don't really say where they are
or how they got there how long this has
been going on
you're kind of presuming that the
shepherd
you know the guy that's kind of like the
head of the cult even though he doesn't
really look all that old he's probably i
want to say mid-30s i'm not really sure
how old that actor is but he doesn't
look very old
but he's he must have been doing this
for at least 14 or 15 years at this
point because
they don't really say there's a couple
of little girls in the cult you know
maybe like eight or nine years old
and you're presuming that he fathered
those with some of his wives
and you're presuming also that he
fathered sela but i'm not
entirely sure about that i mean i
thought i thought that was the
implication
but to see that's the thing it's like
there's a lot of stuff about this and
i'm not sure
i'm not sure if i found it like
detrimental to the movie or not that
there's a lot of stuff
about the cult that is left to your
imagination
let's say that um like i said you don't
know
which of the you know daughters or
sisters or whatever in the cult that he
fathered
if these are people that came to him
later
like like for example like maybe some of
the older wives
maybe they already had a daughter and he
got both of them involved in it or
whatever they don't really
get a lot into that they don't really
get a lot into
their belief system um it is
presumably some kind of fundamentalist
christian-y type of thing
but it's not super specific uh it is
kind of like
you know your basic patriarchal you know
i'm the dude in charge of everything and
you guys are all my wives and
you know it so it's so it's very sister
wivesy kind of mormony kind of
stuff where and he's just like i'll pick
you know they have their communal
meal or whatever and then after the meal
is over he'll come and like pick which
wife he wants to sleep with that night
and
but then there's like creepy [ __ ]
happening too because
as soon as one of the younger girls like
the you know the sister daughters
whatever
as soon as they start getting their
period then he starts looking at him
like
now i'm gonna need you to like replace
like some of these wives that are
getting too old for me
so it's just this really really terrible
kind of situation
um you know so it's like super super
creepy uh another thing too is that
and i really really liked this visual
and i'm sure it's maybe as symbolic of
something but i couldn't really think of
what it was
but every time he like every room that
they have and every
time he gives like a sermon or something
like out in the forest
like the place that he gives a sermon
out in the woods is like there's all
this string
and it's like and it kind of goes around
all the trees so it's almost kind of
like making a room but it's like out of
string
and then in the dining hall there's like
string all over
the ceiling almost like a cat's cradle
so i don't know if it's something like
symbolic of maybe a spider's web or you
know something like that because that
was kind of the first thing that i
thought of
the one that's out in the woods doesn't
look like a spider's web it just looks
like it looks like a bunch of string
like in a
box sort of shape but the one that's up
in the um dining hall definitely
gives a spider web type of vibe and
there is like a very deliberate shot of
him
standing up for the table before he
picks the wife for that night
and uh you can see you know the the
crisscrossing cat's cradle strings like
on the ceiling like over him
so i do kind of feel like maybe that was
the symbolism there that it's just kind
of like this web that you can't escape
so some of the girls including stella
the main character she
has been born in this cult so she
doesn't know any different
um so when we start she's just right on
the cusp of womanhood
i guess and uh the shepherd seems like
he's taken kind of a shine to her
and he gives her um a really important
task where she's supposed to
oversee this one because they also have
like a small little flock of sheep
uh that they tend to and there's you
know one ram as well which is
again a metaphor for the cult being one
ram one dude and then you know the rest
of the
uh the cult members are women and
they're like under his control
or whatever so she's kind of given the
task to go help out this pregnant
you give birth to her lambs
so she takes this as a very important um
you know kind of job which it is
and you know at least at the beginning
just like all the other women in the
cult
um everyone's kind of like vying for his
affection i don't want to make it seem
like in the movie like oh everybody's
backstabbing [ __ ] or anything like
that it's nothing like that at all but
everybody is kind of trying to gain
favor with him because they see him as
like this messianic sort of
figure so there is like little petty
jealousies and stuff like you know one
of the wives says some
smart ass comment about you know
remember when he used to look at us like
that when he's looking at the younger
girls you know because now the wives are
in their 40s or 50s or whatever and
they're not young and beautiful anymore
so
he's you know moving on to younger
targets uh so you know they make little
statements like that but it's not
overdone or anything
so she goes out to do this thing with
the lamb and she ends up up on the
mountain and she falls asleep
and you're not entirely clear because
the thing about this
if this movie has like kind of a surreal
aspect as well there's a lot of
you know sort of visions there's a lot
of like nightmare imagery there's you
know imagery of her
in a river like with a white gown on
she's they're being baptized
or she's drowning um there's a lot of
shots of like dead animals like she
sees a bird like a dead bird that sort
of is covered with maggots
um and things like that so you're not
real clear i mean
it's pretty clear what the symbolism is
but you're not really sure sometimes
what exactly happened because when she
gets this
uh you know this duty to go and help
this you give birth
she messes it up somehow so she falls
asleep
and then the u gives birth and either
the sheep died on its own or she claimed
later that
that she fell asleep in a wild dog came
and got one of the lambs and killed it
um but then there was some shots of her
stabbing the lamb
as well i don't know if that was like
stabbing it because she was like
because it was suffering or whatever but
in any case she kind of messes it up
you know and that kind of leads to
her being punished for that kind of
leads her on this sort of journey
to sort of questioning the authority of
the shepherd
and seeing how maybe this situation that
they've put themselves in
is kind of [ __ ] up so
this i would call it it's sort of like a
coming-of-age
type of story you know her kind of
owning
not only her womanhood because at some
point you know she gets her period and
she's like freaking out because this
cult
they have a thing where you know it's
eve sin
and you know you're impure and you have
to go to the menstrual hut or whatever
it's like that kind of thing
so you have to go there like every time
every time you get your period they
stick you out in the hut because you're
like unclean or whatever and nobody
wants to touch you and
you know it's you're contaminating
everything so it does have that sort of
thing
but you know once you've had that happen
to you also that means you're fair game
for
shepard like then you can graduate to
being one of his wives
and you can get his grace you know
meaning the d that's that's what the
grace is
so probably the instigating incident too
is that at some stage as i said i'm
presuming they just found this place out
in the woods like all these abandoned
cabins or whatever
like i said i don't know how long
they've been there you're led to assume
that it's
probably been at least a decade because
some of the you know younger girls seem
to have grown up there and they don't
know any other home
so they've been living there for however
long but one night
and and this is the moment that you know
that this isn't set like a long time ago
that this is actually kind of set
in the modern day um stella is looking
out the window one night and she sees
that a cop car
has pulled up to the compound or
whatever and is talking to the shepherd
and basically saying you can't hear a
lot of what they're saying but the cop
is basically
you have to leave so i don't know if
they have to leave
because they're trespassing or if
somebody heard about their shenanigans
or whatever it was but in any case i
assumed it was
trespassing or they were on federal land
or something like that but they
you know they don't give a reason they
just say you have to get off this land
so they all kind of pack up and leave
and i think during this journey because
most of the movie is comprised of this
you know obviously they're all just like
camping and walking and [ __ ] like that
they don't have cars or
wagons or anything they just all have
backpacks and they're
kind of looking for a new place and it
becomes very obvious that the shepherd
he's supposedly leading them to a new
place and he's all happy and we're going
to go to eden and all this other stuff
but obviously the [ __ ] doesn't know
where the [ __ ] he's going and he's just
kind of hope hopes that he like stumbles
upon a good new place or whatever
so doubt and dissension kind of start uh
you know
making their way particularly sella not
so much the other girls although
some of them are kind of get a little uh
weirded out too
especially when a couple of sort of
tragic things happen along the path and
like i said this is a fairly new movie
so i don't really want to spoil it for
people i'm not going to spoil the end or
the plot points or anything
but um something really bad happens
while they're on the journey
and that kind of makes some of the women
question his leadership as well
and uh probably one of the most
significant things
is sella's relationship
with this woman named sarah who
was apparently um one of the first
women to join the cult it was actually
her and sela's mom now stella had never
knew his new her mom because her mom
supposedly died when
you know giving birth to her so sarah
you know so she's kind of like she's
older
now at some point she did something
that pissed off the shepherd and he
basically cursed her they you know the
other uh women in the call call her the
cursed woman and she kind of has to live
in another you know in another
cabin like away from the others and um
you know
the shepherd calls her a broken thing
but no one really knows
what her sin was all she said was it was
her vanity so i don't know if she
knows what she quote unquote did wrong
like to piss him off or if
it was just some kind of thing where you
know he decided he didn't like her for
some reason so he just had to make up
some [ __ ] reason i
imagine it's the second thing you know
so she's kind of been cast out and
she still hangs around the group because
she doesn't really
i mean she they have a conversation her
and sella and she's just basically like
well i don't really i've been here so
long that i don't know who i am anymore
so i'm kind of like afraid to leave i'm
essentially saying that she doesn't
really have anywhere else to go you know
stella's relationship with her
is kind of like a big catalyst for you
know
what ends up happening toward the end
and like i said things start getting
worse and worse and more horrific and
everything
and i won't spoil too much of it because
if you're real
into kind of art house war if you like
the witch if you like kind of focori
kind of stuff
you would really really probably dig
this it's
i will say the story it doesn't have
like a real
i mean the story is compelling but
there's not a lot to it
a lot of it is visuals now some of the
symbolism
i feel like was kind of a little on the
nose
you know what i mean basically being you
know sheep flocks
uh you know kind of coming of age blood
sacrifice you know
growing up womanhood all this kind of
stuff you know it's not like real deep
or
anything like that and it doesn't go too
much as i said into
the history of the cult or where these
where all these different women
came from why they stay there why they
joined
you're just kind of coming at it really
just kind of in the middle of things
you don't really know most of these
women's names it's like you don't really
know
you know where they came from what what
their problem was how long they've been
there
um what their beliefs are and all these
other things
but in a way i don't know i kind of feel
like some reviews that i read had a
problem with that they're just kind of
like well you know maybe they should
have gone a little bit more into
the dynamics of this cult like what
makes these women stay there despite
um the conditions you know which you can
probably imagine i mean
it's that's the thing it's like it's a
cult led by
one dude who thinks he's like a jesus
figure
and he has all these wives and daughters
um
who will pretty much just do anything to
please him so you can pretty much
imagine where that goes um you know what
i mean so it's not
it's not like reinventing the wheel if
you've seen any kind of like cult movie
like this
i don't know it's so i kind of found the
cult aspect like intriguing but it is a
little
thin in the sense that you wanted to
know more you wanted to know more about
you know what happened with sela's mom
what happened with sarah the cursed
woman like what happened
um you know why did why did she get kind
of cast out but she still kind of stays
there
i mean i think her character and
stella's character are the most well
developed
um because at least they have a couple
of conversations and you can kind of see
where they're coming from
but the other women you're not really
sure
you know what their backstories were and
i'm not saying that it needed to be
bogged down and all of that like with
exposition and blah blah
you know maybe it's better that it was
kind of just left ambiguous
and um you know the whole thing with all
the strings and everything like that and
how long the cult's been going on
where this was um you know how how
like how did he end up that way you know
what i mean like what's his
origin story so i i do kind of feel like
i wanted to know more about that
but then when i think about it i'm kind
of like if that had been in the movie
would it have just like bothered me like
oh i didn't need to know that because
sometimes i say like
with movies like this this kind of just
like visually arresting
sort of unsettling story
sometimes it's better to just leave
stuff unexplained i mean even though
people will complain about it
but as i said it's almost kind of like
you're taking a peek into
this cult that exists and
if you were if it was real life and you
were kind of just like a fly on the wall
and you were watching them they wouldn't
be exposing about where they came from
their histories or anything like that
so in that way it's kind of like a
little bit more realistic i guess
but yeah like i said too this is kind of
like there's a lot of surrealist
sort of stuff in this i'm you know not
crazy but
she uh sela in particular has a lot of
visions um nightmares things like that
and at one point like one really weird
one where
she's kind of standing on the mountain
when they're you know kind of marching
toward
wherever their new eden is gonna be and
they've been like walking for days and
days
um and she sees on the highway she sees
a car go by that has a girl sitting in
the bed like just a regular teenage girl
with a letterman's jacket or whatever
that
looks just like her well because it's
played by the same actress but you know
so it looks just like her
so you're assuming i mean obviously
that's not her because she was born
in the cult so she's having a vision
perhaps of
what her life could have been like or if
she leaves the cult now what her life
could be like potentially in the future
so there's a lot of kind of dream like
imagery that's not really
you know set off from the regular
imagery so like i said you know
like with the scene of her like stabbing
the lamb
you're not entirely sure if that
happened or
if she was telling the truth that a wild
dog really did get it
and you know so so there's that kind of
thing too a lot of stuff is not
explained
and as i said i'm not sure that it
necessarily had to be
but your mileage may vary on that now i
will say this isn't
it it is very similar to the wit it's
kind of like the witch cross with
handmaid's tale sort of you know kind of
like that with a little bit of midsummer
in there as well
so if you like those movies um you'll
probably dig this one as well i don't
think it's quite as good as those
but it's up there i mean i really i
found it really
beautiful to look at and there was just
this sort of
creepy like underlying sense of menace
the whole time
i think the guy that played the shepherd
was actually really good because
he didn't even have to be overtly
abusive but he just had this kind of
undercurrent of menace it's like yes he
got he did like some abusive [ __ ]
obviously abusive [ __ ] like later on but
for a long time he was just very
soft-spoken but he was just very
menacing nonetheless so i think it was
like a really good performance
but you know what raffy cassidy though
she kind of stole this movie i mean she
just has this
you know her facial expression she just
has this kind of luminous
looking face and you could just see
because she didn't really talk all that
much but you could kind of see like all
her internal conflict and stuff like
that just going on
behind her eyes you know i mean like in
her facial expressions so it was like a
really really good
performance i thought as i said the
visuals are beautiful i really really
liked the juxtaposition
of all the wives and daughters dresses
which were very solidly colored and very
like saturated
against this sort of washed out
mountainous
fountain you know forest kind of
background i thought it was really
really
visually striking and it looked really
cool and uh you know a lot of the
nightmare imagery was
really interesting and like i said this
isn't it's not a scary movie it's not
scary
it's more i don't know it's more like
disturbing i guess or just kind of an
unsettling sort of film in that sort of
line
so you know if that sounds like
something that you
would be into then uh go on over to hulu
at least
if you're in the us i don't know about
other countries but if you're uh in the
us it's on hulu
at the moment as of this recording uh so
check it out and let me know what you
thought about it in the comments
and i will talk to you guys on the next
one bye